BEING HERE. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FOUR SEVEN EIGHT SIX
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
WEBSITE FOR OUR- COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED.
AND YOU WILL THEN BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. CAN
YOU MUST SPEAK CLEARLY AND YOU
MUST SPEAK LOUDLY. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY HERE
THIS SIDE EACH SIDE WILL ONLY
BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES. FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIESMAY BE HEARD. WE HAVE
THIRTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA AT THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST
ONE MEASURE HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM TODAY'S AGENDA. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. SEVEN SEVEN
TWO. THERE ARE TWO MEASURES
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT ITEM
TWELVE SB EIGHT OH EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO EIGHT AND ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN S. B. EIGHT TWO SIX.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON
THE BILL'S LET'S ESTABLISH A
POOR A QUORUM. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE MAKE SURE
TO HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE ON
ROSS. ROSS HERE ARCHULETA. OUR
CHILL OUT HERE MELENDEZ BEATS.
BAKER DODD. YOUR DODD HERE
EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE HER TADO HER
TADO HERE JONES LEYVA. LEYVA
HERE MAN. I MEAN HERE NEWMAN.
NEWMAN HERE A SHOW OF BOGUE.
BUT CHAU ABODE HERE PAN. WE
HAVE A QUORUM BEFORE WE PROCEED
FURTHER WITH OF OUR FIRST
PRESENTER CENTER SKINNER LET'S
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SEARCH A
LITTLE MOVES CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB EIGHT
EIGHT N. S. B. EIGHT TWO SIX.
TO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROSS HI ROSS HI MELENDEZ
ARCHULETA HI ARCHULETA IBEATS.
BACKER OF DODD ALL RIGHT DODD
AYE. EGGMAN HI HER TADO. HER
TADO I'D JONES LEYVA HI LEYVA
MIN. FIVE MILLION HI NEWMAN AYE
NEWMAN AYE AYE TO A VOGUE. THIS
IS ON CONSENT HI BUT CHAU
ABOGADA PAN. BATES HI BATES HI.
WHAT IS TEN ZERO WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SKINNER WELCOME YOU OF ONE
BUILDING PERCENT TODAY SENATE
BILL THREE NINE EIGHT. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE PURPOSE OF SB THREE
NINETY EIGHT IS TO SUPPORT THE
CREATIVE PROCESS THAT WOULD
HELP SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF
ANY ACCESS TO OUR CANNABIS MORE.
HAS ARE KNOW VOTER OF PROP
SIXTY FOUR FOUR YEARS AGO.
HOWEVER ONLY A THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE LEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESSES
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION. AND
WE REMAIN IN A SITUATION WHERE.
THREE OUT OF A. FOUR SPENT ON
AND CAL IS SPEND IN THE ILLICIT
MARC. NOW ONE OF IS THAT MAY
LOOK. DON'T HAVE THE STATE
CAPACITY TO DO THE REQUIRED.
ORDINANCE LICENSE ACROSS AND
REGULATIONS THAT- ARE REQUIRED
UNDER PROP. SIXTY FOUR
THIRTEEN. THIS UNDER SIX FOUR
HAS THE ABILITY TO LIE. BUT IT
KIND OF IT'S KIND OF A DEEP IN
IT OWN OCCURS IF THE- IF THE
BUSINESS SUPPLIES IN THE
LOCALITY THEN AFTER SIXTY DAYS
DOESN'T- HOWEVER THERE ARE
STILL THINGS THAT THE LOCALITY
HAS TO DO WHICH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MAY NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO. SELL WHAT SB THREE
NINETY EIGHT DOES IS FORMALIZES%
A PROCESS FOR A LOCALITY TO
ENTER INTO IT WITH THE STATE
INTO A CANNABIS LICENSING
AGREEMENT SO THAT BUSINESSES
CAN GET THEIR LICENSE THROUGH
THE STATE THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO OPERATE NOT ONLY STATE. BY
THE STATE'S RULES BUT ALSO
WITHIN THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. IT ALSO DIRECTS
THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
TO CREATE EQUITY OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE IT LOWERS THE LABOR
PEACE THRESHOLD AGREEMENT FROM
TWENTY TO. TEN EMPLOYEES AND
THEN ONE KEY POINT THE ONE OF
THE MOTIVATIONS OF COURSE FOR
BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR THE
LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS IS TO
BE ABLE TO. GET THE REVENUE
FROM THE TAX RELATED TO IT AND
SO IF THEY IF THE STATE GIVES
THE LICENSE AND NOT THE
LOCALITY WHAT HAPPENS DOES THE
LOCALITY GET ANY REVENUE FROM
THIS TRANSACTION. AND THERE WAS
A- COMPONENT OF THE BILL WHEN
IT WAS BEFORE GIVEN FINANCE
THAT WOULD HAVE WOULD HAVE
ENABLED THAT HOWEVER WE REMOVED
ANY OF FOR. WE ARE STE WE'RE
WITH THE ACT TO FILL OUT WHAT
THE APPROPRIATE. WOULD BE AND
WE HOPE TO LAND ON THAT BY
PROBES- BUT OTHERWISE THE BILL
THAT IS BEFORE YOU AND- IT IS-
IS WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO BE
VOTING ON TODAY. AND NOW I
WOULD LIKE MY WITNESSES- AMY
JENKINS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND ROBERT HARRIS FROM SEIU
CALIFORNIA TO TESTIFY. MISTER
MISTER FOR PROCEED PLEASE KEEP
IN OR TIME CAN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS IN THE
TANK AND WITH PRECISION
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WHAT THE OP FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT TELL
THE SPEECH TO. CONSUMER ACT TO
LIVE AND IT. HIS LEGAL CANNABIS
AND HAS EIGHT CONSIDERABLE. BUT
THE RIGHT. FREE TO THE FACT.
THAT THE THESE CHALLENGES LEGAL
CANNABIS BUSINESSES MATHIS FOR
THE CANCEL LAST YEAR ALONE
CALIFORNIA'S LICENSED INDUSTRY
GENERATED MORE THAN FOUR POINT
ONE BILLION IMPOSSIBLE FAILED A
50% INCREASE FROM THE PRIOR
YEAR. SHE FROM. ALTHOUGH TO
OVER A BILL DOLLAR. THE LIFE
AND HAVE BOTH THE SIGNIFICANT
GROWTH. ROUGHLY TWO FOURTH WELL
PAYING JOBS RESULTING IN MORE
THAN FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND FULL
TIME PSITION. DESPITE THE
INDUSTRY. CONTRIBUTION TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY ONLY ONE OF
THREE DOLLARS SPENT ON CANADA
IN CALIFORNIA ARE SPENT IN THE
LEGAL MARKET. EARLY DUE TO THE
FACT THAT ONLY THIRTY TWO PER
OF. FIVE FOUR CITIES COUNTIES
OPERATE RETAIL BUSINESSES.
JUSTIN THE POTENTIAL IF MORE
COMMUNITIES OPEN THEIR TO THE
LEGAL INDUSTRY SB THREE NINE
EIGHT OFFERS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS A MORE
STREAMLINED APPROACH TO PROVIDE
SAFE REGULATED CANNABIS AND
WILL HELP CURB DEMAND FOR AND
LIKE. PRODUCT. THIRTY THREE WE
ARE. WERE YOUR FOR AT THREE
EIGHT TWO IN THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
MISTER HARRIS MISTER. MISTER
CHAIR ROBERT YOUR BEHALF LC I
CAL. SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
TO MEMBERS THIS THE PURPOSE OF
FEATURE UNIQUE THE GET HER TO
ONE IN A CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
AND BUILD AND THEIR- OF WORK
WHEN USED BY AT RISK
POPULATIONS THREE NINE EIGHT
WILL THE LEGAL THIS DOWN THE
INCREASE REVENUE TO FUND CHAU.
THE BEST THING YOU CAN DO SNACK
ABOUT THEM ON GROW AND IN THE
PREVENTION PROGRAM AND
COMMUNITY FOR MEMBERS LIVE THE
L. A. L. A. WE THIS WILL
INCREASE CANOPY TAX REVENUES ME
TO SIX HUNDRED MILLION AND A
BILLION DOLLARS DANIEL LEGAL
MARKET EXPANSION IS ALSO THE
MOST AFFECTED TO REDUCE NEEDLE
MARKET. PROP SIXTY FOUR. BUT
CALIFORNIA LEE THE WAY ON
RACIAL JOBS SOCIAL AWKWARD AND
MORE CORPORATE IN CANADA THIS
YEAR NEW YORK NEW JERSEY
VIRGINIA AND NEW MEXICO HAVE
SURPASSED THE- SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT BULLET CALIFORNIA LEAD
THE WAY ONCE MORE. AS YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA STANDS WITH THE
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS THE
TEAMSTERS AND UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS TO EXPAND
THE LEGAL MARKET AND REDUCE THE
UTILITY MARKET PROTECT PATIENTS
IMPROVE WORKER PROTECTION. AND
ENSURE GRACE JUST AND SOCIAL
LIFE. BY REQUEST YOUR PRESS THE.
THREE NINETY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER MS JENKINS NOW WE WILL
HEAR FOR ANY WITH HERE IN THE
GAS AND SOME I SEE NO WITH. ARE
THERE ANY WHAT IN ONE- TO TELL
IN SOME OF SAY BILL THREE NOW
EIGHT. I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES
THANK W WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE WAY WAIT TO. VIA TELE OF.
MIGHT IF WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
OF A WAY TEST IN SOME. OF BILL
THREE NINE EIGHT WE WERE BEGIN.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON ONCE
AGAIN IT YOU'RE SUPPOSE OF S.
THREE EIGHT PRESS ONE THAT ZERO
ONE TOUCH PHONE. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO A NUMBER TWENTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I REMEMBER GRANDMA ON
THE OF C. KHALIFA OUT OF JOSE
AND STRONG. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MEXICO LINE NUMBER TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. EACH GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIR SENATOR. TO
RECEIVE LOW ON THE OF THE OF
THE COAST IS OF. B. THREE NINE
EIGHT. NEXT TO A LINE OF TWENTY
PLEASE CALL. GOOD MORNING I'M A
SEVERAL AREN'T HAPPY TO THE
COURT CONCEPT AND LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WITH OUR AND FOR
THANK YOU. NOW GO LINE NUMBER
EIGHT PLEASE CALL. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN I'M CENTERS CAN THIS
IS A TO RECALL ME ON UNITED
FOOD WORKERS THEIR HUNDREDS
FIVE MEMBERS AND CAL. IT'S TO
THE SUPPORT IF MAN WE HAVE A
NEW OF A WERE WITH ON THE ALTAR
INCLUDING SOME REP FOR OR FOR
FINANCIALLY PROTECTION. ENHANCE
ENFORCED TRANSFER AND SOCIAL.
THANK YOU. NOW ONE NUMBER TWO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NUMBER TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CHAIRMEN OF THE SUPREME A
ABOUT OF KEY THAT IN SUPPORT OF
SB. NINETY EIGHT. OKAY NUMBER A
LINE OF THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE SHOULD MEMBER GEORGE
ON BASS OF AND SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE THE. NINETY AND ONE AGAIN
LAYS OF YOUR ANSWER OF THREE
NINE EIGHT PRESS ONE OF THE
ZERO AT THIS. MISTER SHEPHERD
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR NOT FOR THE SAME.
IN HERE FOR MY AS. IN THE
WITNESSES IN THE GAS IN UP. I
NONE OR THEY'RE IN WITNESS IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WHICH TEST OF
IN UPPER. TO SENATE THREE NINE
EIGHT I SEE NO SO WAY. THANK A
NOT MOVE TO THE WAY WAITING TO.
THE TO. OF UP. BUT IF YOU WOULD
PUT PRO ANY SO AND OF. WHERE
TO. WE WILL THEN. THANK YOU ONE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE NOT. SB NINE
EIGHT PLEASE PRAY ONE AND AT
THIS. AND AGAIN UP WITH OF SB
THREE NINE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE MISTER CHIP OF HE WOULD
THIS TIME THANK YOU MISTER
MAHER LET'S NOT BRING DISCUSS
BACK TO COLLEGE IN THE-
COLLEAGUES ANY. COME OR
CONCERNS REGARDING SAID BILL.
NINE EIGHT. I SEE NO HANDS THE
NEW BEEN A MOTION. BY SENATOR
CENTER SKI WOULD YOU TO CALL.
THANK YOU I MISS CHAIR I THINK
WE ALL ARE WE THAT- DF TO LEAVE
GAY IS. OF GOING ON FOR FORTY
YEARS MAYBE LONGER. INVOLVED
THE FOR EFFORT NOT BEEN MY
PRIMARY FOCUS FOR THE PAST
FORTY YEARS I HAVE BEEN ENGAGED
IN IT. THAT WHOLE PERIOD SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE WHEN I
ACTUALLY WAS THE COORDINATOR OF
THE V. OF THE INITIATIVE
CAMPAIGN THAT PASSED THE FIRST
BALLOT MEASURE THAT WAS HELD UP
IN COURT TO DECRY. CAN WHO WE
IN CA. NOW FORTY LATER WHEN OUR
HAVE IT FOR LEAVE. WE HAVE
THREE OF THE K. MORE GILLIS.
AND THAT OF PUT THOSE THAT HAVE
BY THE RULES ARE. LOW AT A REAL
TO. AND I THAT WE WANT. TO MAKE
SURE THE PRO OF THE- WORK. AND
WE NOT WANT HAVE TO GO. CAN'T
AGAIN. SO WE DON'T WANT HAVE TO
SEE UP IN FOR MAY ON THE U.
MORE UNTIL WE DONE. WE TO THAT
THE LEGAL IS EXCESS. AND THAT
ALL THE- ARE AS MUCH AS YOU TO
IT AND THINK THAT. WHAT BILL
DOES IN THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATORS- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB THREE NINE EIGHT DO
YOU PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROSS HI. ROSS I MELENDEZ
ARCHULETA BIRCH A LOT I'D BEAT
SO. BEAT NO BACK BY BACKER I
DODD. DAHLE AYE EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN I HEARD. JONES SO JONES
NO LEYVA ON LEAVE- I'D MADE
FIVE MILLION I NEWMAN. NEWMAN
AYE CHAU ABODE NOW A SHOW ABODE
NO PAIN HI HE AND I. THAT'S THE
NEW NINE THREE NO SUFFICIENT TO
GET OUT BUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO SKINNER.
WELCOME SENATOR
WILL YOU HAVE MEASURE TODAY IT
IS SET BILL. ZERO NINE. PROCEED
WHEN RAY. YEAH. SAID GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS AND-
MISTER CHAIR MY FIRST TIME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE UNDER
YOUR NEW CHAIRMANSHIP AND I
KNOW YOU CAN DO GREAT JOB SO GO
ON IS. I WITH THE YOU TO IS B.
OH NINE WHICH IT EASY MIX IT.
FOR UP TO INTERESTS IS BEGIN
WERE IN PAYING OFF THEIR
STUDENT DEBTS THE PANDA. I WON
TO FOR THANK THE CHIU THE FOR
THE HIGH WORK AND BILL. ALSO
LIKE TO ACCEPT MEMBERS IN THE
NOW. WHICH NEAR THE PHONE THE
BILL TO PASS SERVE UP TIME
INTEREST AND BY CO. AND TO
AVOID ANY ANY. CON OF CREATING
A TEMPORARY LIFE. THE PENTAGON
AS AFFECTED ASK OF OUR LIFE
DURING THE- YEAR. AND HAS HAD
ESPCIALLY HARMFUL AND- INNER.
STUDENTS FOR INSTANCE MANY OF
CALIFORNIA THOMAS TREES
STUDENTS. HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
TRAVEL TO NORTH CAROLINA TO
TAKE THE REQUIRED AND THE
REQUIRED PRACTICAL EXAM.
PREVENTING THEM FROM OBTAINING
THEIR LICENSE IN FROM GETTING A
HEAD TART ON PAYING OFF THEIR
STUDENT DEBTS. THIS BILL
PROVIDES A NARROW SOLUTION TO
ENABLE THE STUDENTS TO OBTAIN A
TEMPORARY LICENSE. AND BEGIN
WORKING UNDER THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION. OF A FULL LICENSED
UP. WITH ME TO PROVIDE EXTRA
TEST FURTHER. IN DID THEN FOR
THIS MEASURE IS DR JENNIFER
COURT. A PER. IN THE DEAN AT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF
OPTOMETRY. THAT MARSHALL B.
KETCHUM UNIVERSITY. DOT CO YOU
MAY PROCEED PLEASE BE COGNIZANT
OF OUR TIME LIMITATIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND FOR
HERE OURCONCERNS FOR THE
FUTURE THAT I CARE WORK FORCE
DURING THE PESIDENT TIME. IT'S
A PLEASURE CAL OF THE IN AT THE
OF THIS CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF
OPTOMETRY I'M REPRESENTING THE
STUDENTS ABOUT TO GRADUATE IN
THE CLASSES TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IN THOSE IN THE CLASS OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND THE THREE
DOCTOR THAT TIME TO PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA. GREATLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CAN. AND X. THE BILL-OF THE PART NATIONAL BOARD%
EXAMINATION THAT ARE REQUIRED
FOR LIKE TWO IN A STATE. ARE TO
INCH CAN BASED EXAM BETTER
PROCTOR AT IN DETECTION. ACROSS
THE COUNTRY INCLUDING CAL. ARE
THREE YOU HEARD IN IN A PERSON
CLINICAL SKILLS THE- EDITED
MINUTES AT ONLY. CENTER NOT
INSURE NORTH CAROLINA. SHOULD
STUDENTS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL. TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
MILES. SEVEN EIGHT TO TAKE THE
THREE. I EXAMS. AT THE STATE
HOME ORDERS SUBSEQUENT YOUR
CULTURE AMHERST ON INTO LIKE TO
PASS WITH CARRIED BY COUNTY
EACH STUDENTS HAVE EXPERIENCE
UNPREDICTABLE DISTRACTION OR
SCHEDULE BOARD EXAMS NEARLY
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. EXAMS
ARE NOT OFFER CONTINUOUSLY
ACROSS THE CALENDAR BUT RATHER
ON A LIMITED NUMBER. WHAT AGE
IS THE RESULT WHEN THERE'S CAN
IT IS TAKING MONTHS SHE HAVE
THE- TO SIT PER RESCHEDULING
COMMITTEE UNPREDICTABLE
PREDICTABLE NATURE THIS
PANDEMIC THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
THAT THE EXAMPLE A CURRENT
SCHEDULE WANTED MINISTERS IT
TAKES SEVERAL MONTHS FOR THE
RESULTS TO BE ANALYZE IN THE
SCHOOL REACHEDTHE STATE OR. AT
THE END THEIR ETHNIC JOURNEY
THE NEW DA ARE AN UNKNOWN
CHINESE REALITY. NEAR GRAY WITH
THAT TO THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN YOU CAN LEARN DEBT. IN THEIR
BILL TO AND THE WORK CRITICAL
BECAUSE THEY'LL BE REQUIRED TO
START PAYING HONEST YOU CAN
LEARN IT EARLY IN. OF IT'LL
TURN PATHWAY TO LICENSURE THAT
DID NOT IMMEDIATELY REQUIRE THE
NATIONAL BOARD EXAMS WOULD
ALLOW NEW DOCTORS TO ENTER THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE AFTER
GRADUATING FROM ONE OF OUR
CREDIT A DOCTOR ABOUT TRUMP
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE HUGE
COMPLETE A RIGOROUS FOR YOUR
CURRICULUM WITH CONSTANT
ATTACHMENT. IN OTHER WORDS
TESTING INCLUDING REGULARLY
DEMONSTRATING COMPETENCY OF
CRITICAL SKILLS AND THINK. BY
DIRECT TO OVER ONE PAY DURING
THEIR SEARCH PORTS YEAR AND
THERE ON THE FOR. IF IS IN
ADDITION FREQUENT PROFICIENCY.
AND IF ACTIVITY SUMMER HALF FOR
THEM ON FROM YOUR YEAR SHE
ATTEMPTS LICENSE ALLOW THEM TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL LINE VISION
CARE. IMMEDIATELY CHARK FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO PROVIDE
TEMPLATE TO SAFELY COMPLETE
NECESSARY NATIONAL BOARD EXAMS
FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
SIDE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN OUR
STATE. THANK YOU THE COIL LET'S
HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT I SEE NONE.
WITNESSES ROOM TWO- TO TEST AND-
OF SENATE BILL FIVE ZERO NINE.
I SEE NONE. SIR WILL PERFORM
MOVE TO THE WAY WERE TO TEST.
ON THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE-
MAYBE I MISSED IT DO YOU- X.
THE AMEND CONTAIN IN THE
ANALYSIS. THREE OF MY OPENING
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THAT'S MY
TO THE WITH WHAT IT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MR
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THOSE INDIVIDUALS WAITED
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL FIVE ZERO NINE. WE WILL
THEN BEGIN. THANKS THE
STRIPPERS AND- WHAT CAN APPEAR
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ZERO NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. AND
AGAIN LATE IN GENERAL IF YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ZERO NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRPERSON I HAVE
NOTHING TO AT THIS TIME PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION LET'S
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE. WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL FIVE ZERO NINE. THERE
APPEAR TO BE NO WITNESSES
PRESENT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THAT'S MOVED WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
OF US IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS IF ANY.
AND WE WILL THEN BEGIN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION SB FIVE
ZERO NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF
YOU'RE NOT POSITION OF SB FIVE
ZERO NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON OF KNOWN IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PERFECT
LET'S NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THE CHAMBER I SEE SENATOR
NEWMAN WITH THE MICROPHONE UP
SENATE-ROOM PLEASE PROCEED. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I AM
ACTUALLY PROUD TO INCLUDE THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF
OPTOMETRY- IS ONE OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SOLUTIONS MY
DISTRICT- AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT I
JUST WANT TO NOTE HOW STRANGE
IT IS. THAT OPTOMETRISTS IN
TRAINING HAVE TO GO TO SOUTH
CAROLINA FROM CALIFORNIA- TO
COMPLETE PART THREE OF THEIR
EXAMINE SO IN ADDITION
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. I
WOULD URGE IS IT SOME POINT TO
TRYING TO VICE A BETTER
SCENARIO FOR CALIFORNIA'S UP
COUNTY SUDENTS. TO MORE EASILY
GET. THEIR LICENSE IN MOVING
THE WORKFORCE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR. I THANK YOU AS CHAIR- I
TO- FIRST VOIGTS ONE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
ACTUALLY THE SITUATION IS
UNFORTUNATELY NOT JUST UNIQUE
TO OPTOMETRY FOR EXAMPLE
PHYSICIANS HAVE TO TAKE A THREE
PART LICENSING EXAM TWO PARTS
DURING THE MEDICAL SCHOOL ONE
PART AFTER WONDER DURING THE
RESIDENCY TRAINING. AND THEY
ALSO HAVE THESE CLINICAL SITE
EXAMS WHICH ARE SOMETIMES
LOCATED. LET'S SEE NOT NEAR
WHERE PEOPLE LIVE AND MAYBE IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
AND HAVE TO TRAVEL TO DO SO IN
FACT THERE. ARE SOME ISSUES
DURING COATED WITH- SOME OF THE
PHYSICIAN- IN PERSON LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS. AS WELL NOT AS
BAD AS WHAT'S HAPPENING UP
THOMAS TREE RIGHT NOW- I WOULD
MAKE NOTE I APPRECIATE THE-
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE I
THINK A VERY IMPORTANT- ONE
QUESTION I DID HAVE JUST TO
CLARIFY NOTING THAT THIS IS A
THREE PART EXAM- THE- I
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES REALLY
WITH THE THIRD PART WOULD HAVE
TO GO IN PERSON TO NORTH
CAROLINA. THE FIRST TWO PARTS
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING ARE
ACTUALLY TAKEN WHILE AN
OPTOMETRY SCHOOL. SO IT'S NOT
CLEAR FIND AT THE END
AMENDMENTS THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT TO ACTUALLY PASS AT
LEAST PART ONE INTO WHICH THEY
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN BEFORE THEY
GOT THEIR- GRADUATION. BEFORE
THEY GET THE TEMPORARY LICENSE
SO YOU'D HAVE TO BOTH GRADUATE
AND ALSO PART AT LEAST PASS THE
LEASE THE FIRST TWO PARTS OF
THE LICENSING EXAM- JUST
EXEMPTING THE THIRD PART UNTIL-
THEY- RESOLVE THIS ISSUE AND I
WOULD ALSO JUST QUICKLY MAKE
NOTE THAT- THIS A TRY AS A
COMMENT TO PEOPLE LIKE TO RUN
THE LACING EXAMS WHETHER IT'S-
OPTOMETRY MEDICINE THAT SUPPORT
MEDICAL EXAMS OTHERS THAT THEY
HAVE TO DO MUCH BETTER. IN
MAKING THEIR EXAMS AVAILABLE
SAFELY TO STUDENTS OF PEOPLE
GET THE LICENSE BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER COMMENT SO JUST IF I
CAN GET A QUICK ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. SIR WILK THE ANSWERS
QUESTIONS YOU OBVIOUSLY READ
THE BILL BECAUSE OF THOSE THOSE
ARE THE AMENDMENTS SO. GRADUATE
AND THEN PASS ONE PART ONE INTO
BEFORE YOU COULD RECEIVE A
TEMPORARY LICENSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED UP YOU HAVE TO MOVE THE
BILL APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
SIR PLAN FOR MOVING THE BILL
CENTER WILL COULD JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
ON THE AMENDED CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATE YOUR-
COOPERATION WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. I WANT TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR INPUT
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
GREAT WORK AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THE MOTION IS PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COULD ON APPROACH. PLEASE CALL
THE- SENATE BILL FIVE OH NINE
DEEP A MAN BUT FOR A MAN AND
REWRITE TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH. ROTH AYE
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
I'D PLEASE HI BATES AYE BACKER
AYE BACKER AYE DODD. DODD AYE
EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE HER TADO
JONES HI JONES I LEYVA ARM
LEYVA I MEAN. MAN HI NEWMAN AYE
NEWMANAYE AYE CHAU ABODE ON A
SHOW ABOUT A GUY PAN. CAN I.
FOUR VOTES ENOUGH CERTAINLY
SUFFICIENT TO GET OUT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANY ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR WILK.
CENTER BATES WELCOME YOU HAVE
ONE BILL TO PRESENT TODAY
SENATE BILL SIX FIVE TWO YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READING. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
SENATE BILL SIX FIVE TWO IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL AS IT WOULD
EXTEND THE PROTECTIONS PROVIDED
IN SB FIVE OH ONE. BY SENATOR
GLAZER IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
ADULTS AS WELL AS PEDIATRIC
PATIENTS. SB FIVE OH ONE
ESTABLISHED NEW REQUIREMENTS
AND MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR THE
USE OF SEDATION IN
ANESTHESIOLOGY AND PEDIATRIC
DENTAL PROCEDURES SPECIFICALLY.
IT REQUIRED THAT FOR PATIENTS
UNDER THIRTEEN YEARS OF AGE THE
OPERATING DENTIST AND AT LEAST
TWO ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL SHALL
BE PRESENT THROUGHOUT THE
PROCEDURE INVOLVING DEEP
SEDATION. OR GENERAL
ANESTHESIOLOGY PERSONNEL WHO IS
CERTIFIED IN PEDIATRIC ADVANCED
LIFE SUPPORT OR OTHER BOARD
APPROVED TRAINING IN PEDIATRIC
LIFE SUPPORT. IN AIRWAY
MANAGEMENT MUST BE SOLELY
DEDICATED TO MONITORING THE
PATIENT AND BE TRAINED TO READ
AND RESPOND TO MONITORING
EQUIPMENT INCLUDING. BUT NOT
LIMITED TO PULSE OXIMETER
CARDIAC MONITOR BLOOD PRESSURE
PULSE CAPITAL GRAPH AND
RESTORATION MONITORING DEVICES.
SB SIXTY FOOD SIX FIFTY TWO
THEREFORE EXPANDS THESE
PROTECTIONS TO ADULTS SO THAT
THE SAFETY REQUIREMENTS DO NOT
STOP ONCE A PATIENT TURNS
THIRTEEN. THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT FOR PATIENTS
THIRTEEN YEARS AND OLDER THE
OPERATING DENNISTON AT LEAST
TWO ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL BE
PRESENT THROUGHOUT THE
PROCEDURE. INVOLVING DEEP
SEDATION OR GENERAL ANESTHESIA
AND THAT THE DENNIS AND ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL MAINTAIN
CURRENT CERTIFICATION IN
ADVANCED CARDIAC LIFE SUPPORT.
THE ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL WHO
ARE CERTIFIED IN ACLS SHALL BE
SOLELY DEDICATED TO MONITORING
THE PATIENT. TRAINED TO READ
AND RESPOND TO MONITORING
EQUIPMENT I AM COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR. AND
WITH STAFF STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
BOARD TO ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE
THE PROPER TIME FOR THIS BILL
TO TAKE EFFECT. BY DELAYING
IMPLEMENTATION. THROUGH OF THE
AMENDMENT PROCEDURE I'M ALSO
CONTINUED WORK WITH THE-
PARTIES ON PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL RELATED TO MODERATE
SEDATION. I APPRECIATE THE
WILLINGNESS AND OUT OF YOUR
STAFF. TO SUPPORT TO THESE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. AND AT
THE SAME TIME MAINTAINING
STANDARDS CRITICAL TO PUBLIC TO
PATIENT SAFETY. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING SB SIX FIFTY TWO I
ASK FOR YOUR FIVE I VOTE AND I
AM PLEASED TO HAVE GARY COOPER
WHO REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ORAL AND
MAXILLA. FACIAL SURGEONS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND TO HELP
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER PLEASE PROCEED TO
COGNISANT OF OUR TIME
CONSTRAINTS IF YOU IF YOU WILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GARY COOPER
REPRESENTING CALLIE MISS THE
ORAL MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS
ASSOCIATION. MANY OF YOU
SITTING IN THIS CHAMBER I DON'T
REMEMBER THE DIFFICULT AND
EMOTIONAL PERIOD THREE YEARS
AGO WHEN THIS LEGISLATURE HAD
TO GRAPPLE WITH THE ISSUE OF
MAKING PEDIATRIC DENTAL
ANESTHESIA AT STAKE AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS SB BIBLE ONE MUCH OF
THAT CAST WAS COMPLETED. NOW
THANKS TO SENATOR BATES AND HER
STAFF AND YOUR STAFF. WE ARE
STRIVING TO ACCOMPLISH SAME
RESULT FOR ALL DENTAL
ANESTHESIA. I NOW LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO DR JEFF D. LOWE. TO
DISCUSS THE REAL WORLD
APPLICATION OF THE PROVISIONS
SB. SIX FIFTY TWO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AGAIN PLEASE.
BECAUSE OF OUR TIME CONSTRAINTS
SERVICE. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIVE TWO. MY
NAME IS DR JEFFREY IN LITTLE
PLAN THE PAST PRESIDENT OF AND
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ORAL AND
MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS I'M ALSO
A PROFESSOR OF ORAL AND
MAXILLOFACIAL- FACIAL SURGERY
AT BOTH WESTERN UNIVERSITY OF
HEALTH SCIENCES AND LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY MEDICAL CENTER. I
TREAT PATIENTS ALL DAY EVERYDAY
NEEDS TO ACADEMIC HELP SETTINGS
OR A PRIVILEGE TO TEACH AND
MENTOR THE NEXT GENERATION OF
DOCTORS. WILL BE HALF OF OUR
MEMBERS PRACTICING IN
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB SIX A TEACHER IT WILL
ENHANCE PATIENT SAFETY AND
ENSURE ONE STANDARD OF CARE IN
THE DELIVERY OF OFFICE BASED
DENTAL ANESTHESIA. ANESTHESIA
IS AT THE CORE OF OUR TRAINING
AND PRACTICE OR RESIDENCIA
DUCATION STANDARDS REQUIRE A
DEDICATED FIVE MONTH RESIDENT
ROTATION ON THE MEDICAL
ANESTHESIA SERVICE AS WELL AS
AN ONGOING HEALTH PATIENT
EXPERIENCE IN ALL FORMS OF
ANESTHESIA. ZERO FOUR TO SIX
YEARS OF RESIDENCY TRAINING. WE
ARE TRYING IN MEDICAL ASSESS
AND EMERGE MANAGEMENT ON. WITH
OUR COLLEGE. ARCHERY AND
ABILITY TO DELIVER OFFICE SPACE
TREATMENT SAFELY AND AFFORDABLY
TO PATIENTS. B. R. TEAM MODEL
OF PRACTICE IS UNPARALLELED.
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED SB
FIVE A ONE BY SENATOR GLAZER IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH
STRENGTHENED THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE DELIVERY A DEEP
SEDATIONGENERAL ANESTHESIA TO
PEDIATRIC PATIENTS. THAT BILL
WHICH TAKES EFFECT ON JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO REQUIRES
PRACTITIONERS TREATING PATIENTS
UNDER THE AGE OF THIRTEEN.
OPERATE UNDER A TEAM DELIVERY
APPROACH WITH AT LEAST THREE
INDIVIDUALS PRESENT DURING THE
ADMINISTRATION OF SEDATION AND
GENERAL ANESTHESIA. WILL
FURTHER REQUIRES A TRAINED
ANESTHESIA MONITOR WHO HOLDS
PEDIATRIC ADVANCED LIFE SUPPORT
CERTIFICATION TO BE PRESENT. AS
WELL AS MANDATES THE USE OF
CAPNOGRAPHY BY THE ANESTHESIA
TEAM. SB SIX FIVE TWO WILL
APPLY THE SAME STANDARDS TWO
ADULTS REPLACING PEDIATRIC
ADVANCED LIFE SUPPORT WITH
ADVANCED CARDIAC LIFE SUPPORT
CERTIFICATION WHICH IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE TREATMENT
OF THOSE PATIENTS OVER THE AGE
TWELVE. THE BILL EFFECTIVELY
CREATE TO ONE STANDARD FOR THE
DELIVERY OF DEEP SEDATION
GENERAL ANESTHESIA AND THE
DENTAL OFFICE. SUCH A CHANGE
WOULD NOT ONLY ENHANCE PATIENT
SAFETY FOR ADULTS BUT WOULD
ALSO ELIMINATE CONFLICTING
STANDARDS THAT COULD LEAD TO
CONFUSION IN THE DENTAL OFFICE.
FURTHER THESE CHANGESWILL NOT
ONLY STREAMLINED THE DELIVERY
OF ANESTHESIA BUT THEY WILL
ALSO BRING CALIFORNIA INTO
COMPLIANCEWITH THE NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED AMERICAN DENTAL
ASSOCIATION. AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF ORAL AND
MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS AND
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS STANDARDS FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION OF OFFICE
BASED DENTAL ANESTHESIA.
SEVERAL PRACTITIONERS
ADMINISTERING DEEP SEDATION OR
GENERAL ANESTHESIA SHOULD
ALREADY BE FOLLOWING THE
STANDARDS OF CARE. SB SIX FIFTY
TWO WOULD SIMPLY CODIFY CURRENT
PRACTICE RATHER THAN INFLICT ON
REASONABLE OR UNDUE BURDEN ON
THE DENTAL PRACTITIONER. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SIX
FIFTY TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR NOW WE WILL HEAR
FROM ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT I SEE NO
SNOW WITNESSES WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIX FIVE TWO I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ARVEST.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF.
SENATE BILL SIX FIVE TWO. WE
CAN THEN BE. THANK MISTER
SHEPHERD IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. GOING TO
GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
CENTER DONE THAT WITH THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF ORAL
AND MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. HE. ONE DELAYED
GENTLEMAN WHO ARE SUPPORTED SB
SIX FIVE TWO PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WHERE TO GO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS D MILAN
YOU'RE GOING ON A RETIRED
MILITARY AND CURRENT- PRIVATE
PRACTICE ORAL MAXILLOFACIAL
SURGEON SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. P. SIX FIFTY TWO
FOR THE SAFETY OF MY PATIENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FIRST
THE GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY. WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
AGREES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. LET'S NOT MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCING OF US
IN OPPOSITION MR MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD ONCE AGAIN PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN LATE
IN GENERAL IF YOU IN OPPOSITION
SB SIX FIVE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MORE
MISTER CHAIRPERSON WAIT FOR
THAT FIRST PARTY. I'LL BE JUST
ONE MORE MOMENT. PEOPLE AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS-
BREANNA IN THE CENTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
HE IS CURRENTLY IN A POSITION
OF OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
ALTHOUGH WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. AROUND HIGHER
EDUCATION AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT
WE CAN FIND CONSENSUS.
ADDITIONALLY WHAT THE DA
UNDERSTANDS THE DESIRE TO
UPDATE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
SEDATION PERMITS FOR ADULT WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS SO MUCH
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
COMPLETE THE WORK IT WAS
STARTED WITH A THIRTY FIVE OH
ONE IN REGARD TO PH APARTMENTS.
THE REGULATIONS HAVE NOT YET
BEEN PROMULGATED AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE STUDY BY THE
OPTICAL MORAL HEALTH ANALYZING
ACCESS AND COST ISSUES RELATED
TO DEADLINESS EASY CARE. TO NOT
EVEN UNFUNDED MUCH LESS
STARTED. TO BELIEVE ANY CHANGES
TO IDENTIFICATION AND INCLUSION
IT SHOULD BE EVIDENCE BASED
RATHER THAN BEING BLANKET THE
APPLIED FOR SIMPLICITY SAKE.
ESSENTIALLY BELIEVE THE FOLLOW
UP ON SB FIVE OH ONE INCLUDING
THE TO STUDY IN THE RECORDS. OF
THE DENTAL BOARD AND OFFICE FOR
HELP SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED.
BEFORE MOVING FORWARD WITH
ADDITIONAL POSITION PERMANENT
CHANGES. I THINK. AN INSURING
CAL. LAW REGULAR PROVIDE OKAY
SO. TOOK AND ADULTS. WITH SAFE
AND READY I. TO THE DENTAL. ARE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND ONGOING
EFFORTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. MISTER PERSON AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. THANK YOU LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SENATE FLOOR
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS DR PAN. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- YEAH I
WILL SAY THAT I APPRECIATE. THE
AUTHORS- REMARKS ABOUT-
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- THE
OPPOSITION AND- BUT I ESTIMATE
THAT- I DO SHARE THE CONCERNS
OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION THAT THIS MAY BE
PREMATURE AT THIS TIME- SOMEONE
IS PETERSON AND OF KIDS ARE NOT
THE SAME AS ADULTS AND SO
SIMPLY EXTENDING- GUIDELINES
THAT WERE DEVELOPED FOR
CHILDREN TO ADULTS MAY NOT
NECESSARILY ALWAYS BE THE BEST
THING. DEPENDS BOB I DO
APPRECIATE THAT YOUR PLAN TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION BUT I
THINK AT THIS POINT IN TIME I'M
GONNA LAY OFFS- AT- BUT
APPRECIATE THAT HOPEFULLY- YOU
CAN LAND THE BILL IN A BETTER
PLACE THAT IT KNOWLEDGE IS THE
ON GOING WORK THAT STILL NEEDS
TO BE DONE. TO COME OF THE
PUBLIC EYE LINES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS. SENATOR DODD.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DODD CENTER BATES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND LET ME RECOGNIZE
THE COMMENTS OF MY GOOD
COLLEAGUES ON SENATOR PAN
BECAUSE I THINK I HE FOCUSES ON
THE ISSUES THAT I DO NEED MORE
WORK IT IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
AND I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO MOVE IT UP HE HAD
AT THE MOMENT OF THE ISSUES ARE%
MODERATE SEDATION AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE THAT'S
RECOGNIZED ON. THE TRAINING OF
THE ARM CONSISTENT PERSONNEL
AND CERTAINLY THE ACO LEFT BUT
I THINK THAT THE CONVERSATION
WILL CONTINUE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT AS LONG
AS THE BILL HAS A LITTLE LIFE
SO I WOULD STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
AT LEAST GIVE IT A CHANCE TODAY
AND THEN WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
AND DIE FOR NOT GETTING THERE I
CERTAINLY WILL LET MY
COLLEAGUES KNOW AND WILL
CONTINUE THAT DISCUSSION-
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA DON'T ASSOCIATION
HAS SOFTENED BRAVE SOME
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS BUT THEY'VE
BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN THE
CONVERSATION SO EVERYONE IS
WORKING HARD. TO FIND THE RIGHT
PLACE FOR THEIR SANITY IS AN
IMPORTANT TO A BILL AND SHOULD-
IN IN PARTICULAR WE ARE
BASICALLY FOLLOWING THE
NATIONAL STANDARDS IF WE GET IT
ALL TOGETHER AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TOUGH FOR CALIFORNIA
SO I ASK FOR AN IDOL THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER BATES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE. ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATE BILL SIX FIVE TO
DO POSSIBLE REFER TO COMMITTEE
A- RALPH. ROSS HI MELENDEZ
ARCHULETA MARC BURCH A LOT I'D
BEAT. BATES HI DOCTOR NINE
BAKER AYE DODD DODD AYE EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO JONES BY
JONES I LEYVA I BELIEVE THAT I
AM IN. MAN I'D NEWMAN. NEWMAN
AYE AYE CHAU A BOGUS. ON BUT
CHAO ABOAGYE PAN. THE BILL HAS
ELEVEN VOTE CERTAINLY
SUFFICIENT TO GET OUT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. SENATOR PATTY. YEAH.
YOU HAVE ONE BILL TO- PRESENT
TODAY IT IS SENATE BILL. THREE
ZERO SIX YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY. BRITISH YOUR
DOES IS FINE CENTER AND FIGURED
OUT THAT WAY WE HAVE LITTLE
LESS CLEANING UP THE WILLIAM.
THANK YOU FOR- SENATORS- PLEASE
PRESENT SB THREE OH SIX. WE ARE
AT A CRISIS POINT WHEN IT COMES
TO SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASE
INFECTIONS IN THIS COUNTRY SO
EVEN AS WERE MASON COVERED OVER
THE PAST YEAR. WE'VE SEEN A
TREMENDOUS RISE IN SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASE IN FACT THE
CTCS THE CDC ESTIMATES THAT ONE
IN FIVE PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES HAVE AN STD. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ON THE SIXTY
EIGHT MILLION STD INFECTIONS
WERE REPORTED AND RATES OF
SYPHILIS. COMEDIA AND
GONORRHEA- UP 40% SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN. CALIFORNIA HAD THE
SECOND HIGHEST DIVORCE RATE IN
THE NATION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
EFFECT BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
SIMPLEST RATE AMONG WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE INCREASED BY
SEVEN HUNDRED AND 43% THIS CITY
CRISIS AFFECTS COMMITTEES
ACROSS THE STATE BUT CALIFORNIA
YOUTH PEOPLE OF COLOR GAYS
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER PEOPLE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
OVER HALF OF ALL STDS IN THE
STATE ARE REPORTED AMONG YOUTH
AGES FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
YEARS OLD. AFTER AMERICANS ARE
5100% MORE LIKELY TO CONTRACT
HONORING CHLAMYDIA DENTAL WHITE
COUNTERPARTS. THESE DISPARITIES
ARE EXPECTED TO WORSEN AS A
RESULT OF THE COVE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND YOU CAN IMAGINE
WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN WHEN WE CAN
ALL GET BACK TOGETHER AGAIN. S.
ONE OF THE HARDEST DATA POINTS
FOR ME TO SQUARE HAS TO DO WITH
THE RATE OF CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS. A DISEASE THAT MOST
OF US THOUGHT WENT AWAY WITH
THE VICTORIAN ERA. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE BABIES WERE
BORN WITH CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
IN CALIFORNIA I 9100% INCREASE
IN TWENTY TWELVE. THAT YEAR
DOOR TWENTY STILL BIRDS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DISEASE.
HALF OF THE INTENTIONAL
SYPHILIS CASES OCCUR BECAUSE OF
GAPS IN TESTING AND TREATMENT
DURING PRENATAL CARE. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO CLOSE THAT GAP
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL
SCREENINGS. THIS BILL ALSO
INCREASE ACCESS TO STD
SCREENING AND TREATMENT BY
OPENING UP ACCESS TO FAMILY
PACKED PROGRAM. INCREASING THE
USE OF CALIFORNIA'S EXPEDITED
PARTNER THERAPY OPTION BY
PROVIDERS AND PHARMACISTS.
PERMITTING HIV COUNSELOR SAID
MR RAPID STD TESTS REQUIRING
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR HOME STD
TESTS. CALIFORNIA HAS LAGAN
ENACTING COMPREHENSIVE POLICIES
INCREASE ACCESS TO STD
SCREENING AND TREATMENT THE
PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED STD
RATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY. SB
THREE A SIX STATES TO CONVERT A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S STD
CRISIS BY EXPANDING ACCESS TO
STD CARE AND EQUITABLE WAY.
EXPECT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I'VE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AT THE PRESENT-
NORTHEAST FLINT'S EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS ACTION PROJECT AND
SYLVIA CASTILLO ASSOCIATE.
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT FOR
ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU CENTER PAN
PLEASE PROCEED. HI. I CAN ONLY
SAY- MANY MISTER BASIC PLAN AND
I AM REPRESENTING BLACK
LOOPHOLE ON ACTION PROJECT
COMPUTER REPRODUCTIVE
ORGANIZATION WITH OFFICES IN
LOS ANGELES ADOPTED IN THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
SEEN A STEADY INCREASE IN
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS
GEN BUT AFTER. BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
BLACK CLOAKS AND CLEAR YEARS S.
C. DEBATE ARE APPEARING IN THE
COAL MINE THAT IS LETTING US
KNOW THAT OUR SYSTEMS ARE
BROKEN WE ARE STILL LEANING ON
PEOPLE OF COLOR ISSUES SUCH AS
INCARCERATIONS ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND LACK OF ACCESS TO
ECONOMIC MOBILITY OPPORTUNITIES
AT THE HIGHEST THE RATE ELEVEN
AFTER SCHOOL TO TACKLE THIS
ISSUE SB THREE OF THE CREW THE
CLIPPERS OF THE PROPOSED TO
ATTACKING THE RATE THE CLEANING
ACCESS TO LGBT INCOME
COMMUNITIES FOR TREATMENT.
EXPEDITED THERAPY TREATMENT
EXPANDING RAPID TESTING AND
OTHER INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES
LIKE ACTUAL TESTING A GLUT OF
THE NEED TO THREE PROTOCOLS FOR
COULD BE PEOPLE IS WHAT POINT
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT GIVEN
THAT 15% OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL HERE TO PARTY
SUPPOSEDLY YOU KNOW CAN BE
TREATED WITH ANY BY THE
CONFLICT IS OTHER NEXT IN THE
DAHLE KEY THE LACK OF TREATING
CAN CAUSE PERMANENT DAMAGE.
THEY ARE VERY GOOD AND COMPLEX
ISSUES THAT ARE SURE THAT WE
ARE LOOKING FOR SO MY JACKSON A
COUPLE CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THIS
IS NOT OF THOSE COMPLICATED
ISSUES WE HAVE THE TOOLS TO BE
AND WHERE STARTED A CORNER WE
DO THE AT THE- AND WHY AFTER TO
VOTE YES ON SB THREE OR- BATTLE
SEVEN. ACTING AS THE DEBATE THE
WEEKEND THANK YOU I KNOW WE
HAVE YOU TO YOUR TEST BUT IT
DOES HELP TO SPEAK. LOUDLY AND
A LITTLE SLOWER FOR SO THAT WE
CAN HEAR YOU A MEMBER OF THE
IDEAS THAT YOU SUBMIT IF YOU
HAVE THAT IN WRITING SUBMIT
THAT WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO OUR
COMMITTEE SO THE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY MAY BE INCLUDED.
IN
THE RECORD- AND PROMOTE QUALITY
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL. OUR STI
PREVENTION CENTER IS THE
LEADING RESOURCE FOR BEST
PRACTICES AN STI. SCREENING
TESTING AND TREATMENT AND WE
WORKED IN CLOSE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH- STD CONTROL
BRANCH. COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND OTHER COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS TO SUPPORT THE
DELIVERY OF QUALITY CARE AND
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF STDS.
TODAY'S HEARING COMES ON THE
HEELS OF THE NEW REPORT FROM
THE CDC THAT REVEALED THAT. HE
IRATE HAVE INCREASED ACROSS THE
U. S. FOR THE SIXTH CONSECUTIVE
YEAR IN A ROW. SB SIX WEEKS TO
CURB THIS HIDE. AND PREVENTIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS IN A
PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE WAY.
ARE MEASURE WILL STRENGTHEN OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO STI
COVERAGE IN CARE TO IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES. AND CREATE A
MORE EQUITABLE HOME. ONE
STRATEGY IS TRYING HARD THE OF
THEOF HEALTH FOR. TO PROVIDE
SCREEN AND HAVE. UNTIL
TREATMENT ARE STABILISED THAT
ALLOW THE PRACTICE AS EXPEDITED
PARTNER THERAPY FOR ETP.
PRACTICE ALLOWS HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS TO OFFER PATIENTS
WHO TESTED POSITIVE FOR FPIS.
TREATMENT FOR THEIR PARTNERS IT
IS APPROVING AN EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE. AND ESPECIALLY IN
REDUCES AMONG S. CI CONDITION
AMONG VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND THE CDC CONSIDERED AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN ADDRESSING
THE EPIDEMIC AS NOTED IN THE
FIRST EVER AT TI NATIONAL
STRATEGIC PLAN. THAT WAS
RELEASED IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND
THE MEDICATIONS PROVIDED ARE
VERY SAFE AND NOVEMBER ADVERSE.
REACTIONS HAVE BEEN REPORTED TO
DATE. IT'S TIME THAT WE
MODERNIZE OUR E. P. T. LAWS
BECAUSE THEY ARE OUT OF DATE AS
OF NOW AND THE MEASURE WILL
ALSO ALLOW HIV COUNSELLORS TO
PERFORM RAPID TEST FOR FTI. IN
ADDITION TO THE HIV AND HAD THE
RAPID TESTS ARE ALREADY
AUTHORIZED TO PERFORM. WE KNOW
WHAT WORKS NOW WE NEED ACTION
AND THIS IS WHY WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE TODAY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET'S NOT HEAR
FROM WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWELVE ONE TWELVE AGREES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I SEE NO
SUCH WITNESSES LET'S NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE OVER THIS.
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE POMPT ANY SUCH
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
WE WILL THEN BEGIN. ASSEMBLY
WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE GERMAN. TO
US THE FIELD PRESS ONE AT THE
START. WE WILL NOW TO ONE
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR IN YOUR OPEN
WILL HAVE PLEASE. HI MOLLY-
ROPELESS GRANDPARENT HEADED.
WERE IN STRONG AT THE THREE OF.
THANK YOU. THE LINE TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD PLEASE GOING. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT THE
ARMSTRONG BEHALF OF THE COUNT
HEALTH EXECUTIVE THIRTY RF
HEALTH LOOK HOPE TO. STRONG SB
ZERO SIX THANK YOU. THE LION
EIGHT OPEN HEAD TO. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MARC ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS FOR. OF
LEADING PROVIDER OF STD TESTING
AND TREATMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HE NOW OPENING LINE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CRAIG CALLED HER FROM A
QUE LA HEALTH THE PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINE
THIRTY NINE YEAR OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DO YOU STILL WITH THE
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY- OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. NUMBER OF ERIN
EVANS ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. STORY LINE SIXTEEN LINE
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD I'M GLAD
PLEASE. HEY EVERYBODY AT THIS
PROPERTY HELLO FROM THE LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER ACROSS CO
SPONSOR AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
BRUTAL SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME COMING OUT A
LINE FORTY TWO YEAR OLD
COMPLETES GOING OUT. GOOD
MORNING MEDICARE NUMBERS
ADEQUATELY MORE COMPLEX AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CAPTAIN SISKO AID
FOUNDATION ON PRACTICAL ON
THURSDAY TELL ME ARE AT YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL CALLS IN SUPPORT.
BUT FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS NOW
AND HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FIRST WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY NEXT WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE AGREES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. I SEE NO
SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORDERS. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY WILL BEGIN
WITH THEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE GENTLEMAN
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF US
BETWEEN ZERO SIX PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW. AND WITH A LOCAL IS QUEUED
UP IN OPPOSITION SIR THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR LET'S NOW BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SENATE FLOOR
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS AND CONSERVANCY. THREE
ZERO SIX MOVE THE BILL. BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR LEYVA.
DR PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATE BILL THREE ZERO
SIXTY POSSUM RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROSS HI ROSS I'M MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA I. OCALAN IBEATS.
BACKER DODD DODD AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HI HER TADO JONES BILL
JONES NOTE LEYVA ALL LEYVA AYE
MIN. FIVE MIN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN
AYE AYE CHAU ABODE NO I CHAU
ABODE NO HAN. CAN I. THE VOTE
IS EIGHT TO TWO SUFFICIENT TO
MOVE OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
HOWEVER WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU DR
GRANT. OKAY CERTAINLY WHAT I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU TO CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE IS I PROPOSED TO
PRESENT THE NEXT SERIES OF
BILLS AND WHAT I PROPOSE TO DO
IS TO PRESENT ITEMS SIX THROUGH
ELEVEN. BUT YOU TAKE SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION AND PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THOSE MEASURES AT
THAT POINT. FOLLOWED BY
QUESTIONS FROM ANY MEMBERS.
WITH REGARD TO ANY OF THOSE
MEASURES SIX THROUGH ELEVEN AND
THEN SEPARATE MOTIONS AND VOTES
ON EACH ITEM ITEMS SIX THROUGH
ELEVEN. IS THAT THE SUFFICIENT
VERY GOOD MISTER CHAIR WE WILL
DO IT JUST THAT WAY WELCOME IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU. BUT A NUMBER
SIX SENATE BILL SIX ZERO SEVEN
IS THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE ANONYMOUS BILL CONTAINING
SEVERAL CHANGES TO A NUMBER OF
PRACTICE SEX. ADMINISTERED BY
VARIOUS PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
THE CHANGES CONTAINED IN THE
BILL STEM FROM PRIOR SUNSET
REVIEW OVERSIGHT DISCUSSIONS
AND ARE GENERALLY NON
CONTROVERSIAL BUT SUBSTANTIVE
CODE CLEANUP AMENDMENTS. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS BOARD
AND LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS
TECHNICAL COMMITTEE THIS BILL
ADDS THE APPROPRIATE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE FOR THE PRO THESE
PROGRAMS TO RECEIVE APPLICANT
FINGERPRINTS AS THEIR PRIOR
SUNSET BILL PROVIDED AUTHORITY
TO DO SO. THE BILL ALSO
IMPLEMENTS A COMMONSENSE BEST
PRACTICE BY WAVING INITIAL
LICENSING FEES FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES WHOSE APPLICATIONS ARE
ALREADY PROCESSED ON A FAST
TRACK THROUGH AN EXPEDITED
FORMAL PROCESS. FOR THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
THIS BILL INCREASES THE AMOUNT
OF THE CURRENT BOND BY TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THE BILL ALSO
ELIMINATES BARRIERS TO
PERFORMING NECESSARY REPAIRS ON
EXTERIOR ELEVATED ELEMENTS BY
CLARIFYING THAT A CONTRACTOR
WHO IS ALREADY SUBJECT TO THE
BOARD'S OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT. IN THE EVENT OF
POOR WORK OR FRAUD. MAY INSPECT
FOR AND PERFORM SAFETY
ENHANCING REPAIRS. THE BILL
UPDATES PROVISIONS TO REFLECT
WHAT THE DENTAL BOARD COLLECTS
FOR PEDIATRIC MINIMAL SEDATION.
PERMITS IT ALSO REPEALS THE
CLINICAL AND PRACTICAL
EXAMINATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANTS IN
EXTENDED FUNCTIONS. THE
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANTS
PRACTICAL EXAM REQUIREMENT WAS
REMOVED THROUGH THE BOARDS
PRIOR SUNSET BILL. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- OVER
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. I ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB EIGHT HUNDRED. IS THE
FIRST OF A NUMBER OF SUNSET
BILLS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY THIS
BILL MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
REAL ESTATE LAW INTENDED TO
IMPROVE OVERSIGHT OF REAL
ESTATE PROFESSIONALS STEMMING
FROM THE JOINT SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
REAL ESTATE AND BUREAU OF REAL
ESTATE APPRAISERS. SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND PROVIDES THE DR
REED WITH A THIRTY IN STATUTE
THAT THE FORMER BUREAU OF REAL
ESTATE HEAD WHEN IT WAS AN
ENTITY UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE CHANGES
CONTAINED IN THIS BILL SB EIGHT
HUNDRED PERTAIN SOLELY TO THE
D. R. E. AND NOT. THE B. R. E.
A THE BOARD. OF A REAL ESTATE
APPRAISERS. THE NEXT ITEM ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT S. B. EIGHT ZERO
ONE MAKES VERY SUBSTANTIVE AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE BOARD
OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND THE
LICENSEES UNDER ITS
JURISDICTION WHICH ARE
SPECIFICALLY LICENSED MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPIST LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
LICENSED EDUCATIONAL
PSYCHOLOGISTS THIS BILL WOULD
CLARIFY PATIENT DISCLOSURE
INFORMATION ED CONFORMING
LANGUAGE RELATED TO DENY ALL
PROCEDURES. CLARIFY THAT
ASSOCIATES MAY PROVIDE
TELEHEALTH SERVICES AND EXPANDS
THE CONTINUING EDUCATION
PROVIDERS FOR LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKERS AMONG OTHERS WE
ARE CONTINUING TO WORK ON
SUNSET EXTENSIONS FOR ALL OF
THE BOARDS UP THIS YEAR AND
WILL INCORPORATE A NEW SUNSET
DATE SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE. I
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB EIGHT ZERO
TWO. MAKES VARIOUS TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO THE PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION ACT
ADMINISTERED BY THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
MOVING FORWARD THE MEASURE WILL
BE UPDATED TO REFLECT THE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO ENSURE
STUDENT SUCCESS AND QUALITY
EDUCATION WHILE RECOGNIZING THE
NEED FOR APPROPRIATE
TRANSPARENT REGULATION OF THE
PROGRAMS OFFERING TRAINING AND
EDUCATION TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. AS YOU KNOW THIS
IS A JOINT PROCESS NEGOTIATIONS
ARE CONTINUING SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
MY COLLEAGUES THE BUREAU
SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE AMEND THE ACT IN A
WAY THAT MAKES SENSE AND YIELDS
ARE SHARED GOALS. OF AFFORDABLE
AND MEANINGFUL EDUCATION. BUT
ITEM NUMBER TEN SENATE BILL
EIGHT ZERO TWO. DELETES AN
OBSOLETE REPORTING REQUIREMENT
THAT PROHIBITS THE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE FROM BEING PERFORMED
BY OUR OFFERED BY A BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY.
LICENSEE THE BILL WILL CONTINUE
TO TAKE SHAPE AS WITH THE
OTHERS AS WE WORK COLLECTIVELY
TO UPDATE THE FRAMEWORK BY
WHICH BEAUTIFICATION SERVICE.
LICENSEES ARE TRAINED EDUCATED
AND REGULATED IN THE STATE. AS
I'VE ENTIONED AS YOU KNOW
COLLEAGUESTHE TRADITIONAL
PROCESS FOR THIS COMMITTEE. TO
CONDUCT IT'S IMPORTANT SUNSET
REVIEW OVERSIGHT WORK HAS BEEN
IMPACTED BY NECESSARY CHANGES
IN LIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC. WE
DID HOLD SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS FOR THE
BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY BARELY ONE WEEK AGO
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE BEST PATH
FORWARD FOR THIS PROGRAM. AS WE
WORK TO PRIORITIZE THE SAFETY
OF CONSUMERS BALANCED WITH THE
ECONOMIC LIVELIHOOD OF THE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
LICENSED. BY THIS BOARD.
FINALLY- ITEM ELEVEN SENATE
BILL EIGHT ZERO SIX THE FINAL
SUNSET BILL ARE HONORED AGENDA
TODAY SIMPLY REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT BOARD ESTABLISH A
PASSING SCORE AND TIME AND
PLACE FOR EACH EXAMINATION IT
WILL BE AMENDED IN THE COMING
WEEKS TO ENSURE THE CONTINUED
OPERATION OF THIS PROGRAM. AS
WELL AS THE OTHER BOARD SUBJECT
TO SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT THAT
OVERSEE THE DELIVERY OF HEALTH
CARE BY VARIOUS QUALIFIED
LICENSED PROVIDERS AND WITH
THAT- MADAM CHAIR AT THE
APPROPRIATE POINT IN TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEIR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS- WHEN WE GET THE
QUESTIONS- AT THE END ON ANY OF
THESE MEASURES I HAVE VARIOUS
INDIVIDUAL STANDING BY ON THE
PHONE TO HELP ADDRESS THOSE
QUESTIONS VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR ROTH. MEMBERS
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE GALLERY
AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ANY OFTHESE BILLS SEEING NONE
WE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH SEVEN.
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY THREE OR EIGHT OH
SIX THANK YOU. CERTAINLY THE
GENTLEMAN TO IN SUPPORT OF ANY
OF THOSE BILLS PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO WITH THE STOCK. ONE MOMENT
WE DO HAVE SOME KENYANS. WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY ONE LINE
TWENTY ONE ZERO POINT IS GONNA.
HI MY NAME IS HEARD THEM HOME
I'M THE LEGISLATIVE MANAGER FOR
THE BOARD BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF SB
EIGHT ZERO ONE. THE BOARD IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR THE CURRENT
RESIDENT AT THE IN A ONE.
DOUBLE MINOR TECHNICAL AND
CLEAN UP MAN MAKE SURE THAT THE
LAW IS CLEAR AND CONSISTENT AS
POSSIBLE. INCLUDING CLEANING
AFFECTION THE REFERENCES AND
OUT THAT ARE NOW OBSOLETE AND
CLEAR MAKING CLARIFICATIONS
ABOUT TELEHEALTH AND ALLOWING
THE BOARD TO COLLECT EMAIL
ADDRESSES FOR BETTER
COMMUNICATION. I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ABOUT THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. HELLO NOT A LINE
NUMBER IN. EUROPE BECAUSE. TO
ONE NINETEEN ONE MOMENT
APOLOGIZE. THE LITTLE BIT OF A
GLITCH APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR
ONE NINETEEN YEAR NOW OPEN TO
THE GROUND. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ON SILVER MEULEN
REPRESENTING YOUR MARINE EIGHT
CC. AND SIRTEX INSURANCE
COMBINED THE RIGHT
APPROXIMATELY TWO THIRDS OF ALL
THE CONTRACTOR LICENSE BONDS IN
CALIFORNIA- WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MAJOR THIS IS A RESULT
SB SIX OH ONE IS THE RESULT OF
THE STUDY BY THE CONTRACTORS
LICENSE BOARD. THAT RECOMMENDS
OF THE BOND BE RAISED IN THE
CURRENT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS I THINK A TO
POINT OUT. THAT IT MY CLIENT
9092% ALL BALL HOLDERS THE
CREDIT SCORE SIX OR BETTER
CURRENTLY PAYING. HOW TWENTY
DOLLARS A FOR THEIR FIFTEEN
DOLLARS ON- IT WILL GO UP- S. A
HUNDRED DOLLAR A YEAR FOR THE
ADDED IT THAT DOLLARS IT'S ALSO.
IN KNOW FROM STUDY. THAT THE
CURRENT LET OF FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS COVERS LESSONS. OF ALL.
FILED CONSUMER SO IT'S VERY
THAT THE BOND BE RAISED IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT MY
CLIENTS WILL NOT RAISE THEIR
PERCENTAGE. THAT THEY CURRENTLY
CHARGE FOR THE FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR BOND SCHOOL DISTRICT WE
BE THE ADDED COST- WHICH WOULD
BE LESS THAN A HUNDRED DOLLARS
A YEAR ABOUT I HEARD JAY AYE
VOTE ON SB SIX OF ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE SIX OH SEVEN
EXCUSE ME. THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME MISTER PERSONAL
NOBODY I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS WILL MELT MOVE TO ALL.
ON ITEMS TO A- WITH ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY SCENE NO ONE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM TWO ELEVEN. SEEING
NO ONE MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO YOU AND PLEASE
Q. OF ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. FILE ITEM
SIX THROUGH. ELEVEN ANYONE CAN
AGENTS YOUR IN OPPOSITION HE'S
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE CAN MEASURE FOR YOUR IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTSOR CONCERNS.
ABOUT FARM SIX THROUGH. ELEVEN
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE THEM SEPARATELY.
ANY QUESTIONS SEARCHABLE GIVEN
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NO- SEE NO OF
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. US IN
ROTH WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BEFORE WE START LOOKING FOR
MOTIONS. JUST THE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON EACH
MEASURE IT AS IT COMES FORWARD
THANK YOU CENTER OFF CENTER PAN
AM CHAIR SHOULD A MOVES EACH
ONE IF IT WOULD PLEASE. OKAY
I'M GONNA MOVE. THAT NUMBER SIX
AS BC SEVEN MY NUMBER SEVEN
EIGHT. I AM NUMBER S. B. EIGHT
A ONE I AM NINE SP EIGHT OH TWO
ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B. EIGHT OH
THREE AND ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
EIGHT OH SIX. THANK YOU CENTER
ROTH SB SIX OR SEVEN HAS BEEN
SENATOR PAN SORRY HAVE REMOVED
BY CENTER PANNED OUT OF
CONSULTANCIES CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL SIX ZERO SEVENTY
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROTH. ROSS I MELENDEZ ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I'D BEAT HI BEATS
HIGH BACKER BY BECKER I DODD I
DODD AYE EGGMAN HI EGGMAN AYE
HER TADO HI. HER TADO I'D JONES
HI JONES I LEYVA ARE. LEYVA AYE
MIN. I MEAN I NEWMAN HI NEWMAN
AYE AYE CHAU A BOGUS I A SHOW
ABOUT OAK IPN HI. CAN I. YOU
GOT HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT
WE'LL IT OPEN FOR MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB EIGHT HUNDRED WHICH
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN
MEDICAL CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATE BILL EIGHT
HUNDRED DEEP PASSES AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROTH FIVE. ROTH HI MELINDA'S.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BEAT HI
B. FIVE DECKER HI BACKER I DODD.
DAHLE AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN I TADO
HI HER TADO I JONES HI JONES
I'D LEAVE US ON LEYVA AYE MIN.
FIVE MILLION I NEWMAN HI NEWMAN
AYE AYE CHAU A BOGUS I A SHOW
ABOAGYE HAN HI HE AND I THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES YOU DON'T
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS IN THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB EIGHT OH ONE WHICH IS
THE MOVE BY CENTER PAN AMERICAN
SALUTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IT.
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH ONE DO YOU
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROTH R. ROSS HI MELENDEZ
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HI BEATS
SORRY BEATS BY DR BY BACKER I
DODD. DODD AYE EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
AYE HER TADO HER TADO I'D JONES
HI JONES I'D LEAVE THAT ON
LEAVE THE ICEMEN- AYE. MIN AYE
NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE CHAU
ABODE HI BUT CHAU ABODE IPN HI
HE AND I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT BILL IS OUT LOCAL THE ROLE
WE ARE NOW MOVING TO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB EIGHTY TWO WHICH
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN
BEEN CONSULTED CALL THE ROLL.
HE GOT. THE BILLS OUT THIRTEEN
ZERO. SENATE BILL EIGHT ZERO
TWO DO YOU PASS AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION ROTH
FIVE ROSS HI MELENDEZ.
ARCHULETA HI OCALAN I I'D BE
SIDE BATES AYE BACKER AYE
BACKER AYE DODD. DODD AYE
EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE HER TADO
HI HER TADO I'D JONES HI JONES
I LEYVA ON LEAVE AYE AYES AYE
MIN AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AREN'T
NEWMAN AYE UNTIL ABODE I'M A
SHOW ABOUT I'D PAN HI HE N. I.
THE BILL THIRTEEN ZERO MOVING.
ON TO FILE ITEM. NUMBER NINE SB
EIGHT OH TWO WHICH HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAM AND
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CARENTAN WELL I JUST HAVEN'T
HAD ENOUGH CAFFEINE THIS
MORNING HAVE I THOUGHT WE WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM TEN SB EIGHTY
THREE WHICH IS ALSO BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR PAN MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH THREE DO
YOU PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROTH. ROTH HI MELENDEZ.
ARCHULETA ARGILLITE I'D BE
RIGHT BEATS HI BACKER AYE
DECKER AYE DODD. DODD AYE
EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE HER TADO
HER TADO I'D JONES HI JONES I
LEYVA ON LEAVE THE ICEMEN. MAN
I NEWMAN HI NEWMAN AYE A SHOW
OF BOGUS I'M A SHOW ABOUT AYE
PAN AYE HE AND I THE BILL'S UP
THIRTEEN ZERO WILL MOVE TO THE
LAST BUILD FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB
EIGHT OH SIX ALSO MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN AM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATE
BILL EIGHT ZERO SIXTY PASSING
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH IRA ROSS I
MELENDEZ. ARCHULETA I OCALAN
IBEATS BY BEATS BY DR. AYE
BACKER AYE DODD. DODD I HI
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO ON HER TADO
I'D JONES HI JONES I LEAVE US
ON LEAVE AT AYE MIN ON MAN HI
NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE AYE CHAU
ABODE I A SHOW ABOUT A GUY HAND
BY HAND HI THE BILL IS ALSO L.
THIRTEEN ZERO AND MISTER CHAIR
I WILL TURN HEM ON A CHAIR
FELL BACK OVER TO YOU THANKS.
FOR A JOB. OKAY LET'S SERVE
OPEN ROLE ON THE- OPEN ITEMS
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. I GOT IT
RIGHT LOWS IN ADDITION IT'S- IS
IT OKAY. EVERYBODY WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH THE- CA CAN I'D
FOR AND THIRD A B. A. ZERO S.
EIGHT TO SIX. CURRENT VOTE TEN
TWO ZERO. ON CONSENT MELINDA'S
TAKEN. BAKER HI BAKER I JONES
RIGHT GEN I CAN BY HAND HI THE
CAMPUS HIS THIRD ZERO IS OUT.
WHAT A TOUGH EVEN OFFICE AT
EIGHT THIRTY OFFICE OF. EXTRA
ITEM NUMBER SENATE BILL NINE
EIGHT. I THREE NINE EIGHT DO
YOU HAVE IN RETURN TO THE ON A
PROBE. MULLIN HER TADO NO. HER
TADO NO. WHAT IS NINE TO FOR
THAT MATTER AS FISHING BOATS
THE PURPOSE OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I REMEMBER TO SENATE BILL FIVE
ZERO NINE BIRDS VOTE TWELVE
ZERO. SB FIVE OH NINE KERN VOTE
TWELVE TWO ZERO MELENDEZ REFORM
HER TADO HìNH. HER TADO II.
ONE OF VOEPEL THIRTEEN ZERO
MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE SENATE BILL.
SIX FIVE TWO. SB SIX FIVE Q.
CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN TWO ZERO
MELENDEZ. HER TADO HIGH HER
TADO II HANNAH. BOAT IS TWELVE
ZERO MATTER IS A. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SENATE BILL
THREE ZERO SIX. CURRENT VOTE%
EIGHT TO SB THREE ZERO SIX
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO BE WELL
BATES NO BACKER. HI BAKER I HER
TADO HìNH HER TADO HI. BOOKER
IS A LEAD MELENDEZ. BURKE CHEN
IS TEN TO THREE. MATTER IS OUT.
THE TOP OF THE ROLE AND ITEM
NUMBER SIX SENATE BILL. SIX
ZERO SEVEN. SB SIX ZERO SEVEN
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN TWO ZERO
MELENDEZ. THIRTEEN ZERO MATTERS
OUT ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SENATE
BILL. EIGHT HUNDRED. SB EIGHT
HUNDRED AND CURRENT VOTE
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO MELINDA'S.
THIRTEEN ZERO MATTER IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SENATE BILL
EIGHT ZERO ONE. SB EIGHT ZERO
ONE CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO
MELENDEZ. THIRTEEN ZERO MATTER
IS OUT. THANKS TO ALL WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE TO DO SO YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD IF
POSSIBLE THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
WE HAVE NOW CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA TODAY THE SENATE
BUSINESS COMMITTEE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IS ADJOURNED.